prosecutors are expected to rest their
case this week in the federal trial of
the notorious Mexican drug lord Joaquin
el chapo guzman yesterday a witness
testified el Chapo's wife helped plan
his daring 2015 escape from a Mexican
prison
el chapo has pleaded not guilty to 17
drug trafficking gun and
money-laundering charges
Jericka Duncan is outside the federal
courthouse in Brooklyn
Jericka good morning good morning
prosecutors say rather that El Chapo the
former head of the Sinaloa criminal
enterprise was responsible for a lot of
what many witnesses came forward and
testified and said that he was
responsible for not only terrorizing but
bribing and even killing his way to the
top of Mexico's underworld drugs sex
murder and betrayal since November a
real-life drama has been unfolding in
Brooklyn federal court the villain
according to prosecutors is 61 year old
Joaquin el chapo guzman whose exploits
have been turned into a Netflix series
former associates testified that el
chapo protected his drug pipeline into
the US with violence and bribes
including 100 million dollars to former
Mexican president Enrique Pena Nieto who
denies the allegation what about Chapo's
mistresses said the drug kingpin once
evaded capture through a tunnel under a
bathtub in his safe house without
chiapas wife in the courtroom the
mistress described their naked escape
through a sewer CBS News legal analyst
Ricky Kleman is it me or do these
transcripts read like a soap opera
the only telenovela part of this is
about chapo the wife and the mistresses
but when it comes time for the business
it really does read like fiction
investigators say El Chapo gave orders
to lieutenants and spying on his lovers
using a secure communications network
the man who built that system was a key
witness for the prosecution
the fellow who set up all of the wiretap
set up the encryption then got caught by
the FBI started working for the FBI and
eventually hacked into
zone system for the FBI the day that he
started to testify absolutely turn the
tide of this trial the trial also
revealed various ways the cartel
smuggled drugs through legal checkpoints
you're dealing with planes and boats and
even a submarine you had cocaine going
in two jars of jalapeno peppers for
heaven's sake and while the prosecution
is expected to wrap up we could learn
today whether or not El Chapo will
testify in his own defense Nora and I
like jalapenos
all right tarika thank you right